thanks to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video
we'll need this later as you may have
heard taylor swift is single-handedly
responsible for climate change so
basically um what i was thinking of was
um
ah i can't believe you've done this
marketing agency yard pulled together
records from adsb exchange of which
celebrities have flown in their private
jets the most so far this year and
taylor swift did the most with 170
flights between january 1st and july
19th when the report was compiled doing
so created 8
293 tons of co2 equivalent roughly 500
times the average american's annual
footprint at this rate taylor swift will
produce 15 000 tons of co2 from her
flights alone this year the same carbon
footprint as the bustling metropolis of
caddington in bedfordshire naturally
when this became apparent taylor was
arrested by interpol and is currently
awaiting trial for crimes against
humanity in the hague because we live in
2022 i do need to state that none of
that happened well taylor did use her
private jets a lot look this story was a
huge meme recently and i just wanted to
make a quick video about it because this
article actually sits at the heart of a
fundamental debate in climate action
that uses you as an unwitting pawn this
article was written because it generates
clicks
why the shock of seeing how many private
flights she took this year i didn't even
take one taylor swift having a vocal
army of swifties who will defend her no
matter what seriously will drive further
attention to the story but fundamentally
it plays on the idea of comparing our
individual impacts on the climate this
article makes people angry at taylor
swift's oversized impact on the climate
compared to their own you see we've been
for lack of a better word conditioned to
assess our impact on the climate
compared to others and i want to be very
clear that you
watching this video right now you
have an impact on the earth's climate
there are any number of websites that
will tell you your carbon footprint
based on how many flights you take a
year your diet how much stuff you buy
all that kind of thing and the more
carbon you
put into the earth's atmosphere the more
the planet warms as an individual
knowing that i have an impact on the
climate i try to keep that impact as
small as possible so i'm vegan i don't
fly i source all of our electricity from
renewable suppliers and yet i also
understand that that makes next to no
difference all my actions together save
perhaps four tons of co2 equivalent per
year which compared to the approximately
35 billion tons of co2 emitted globally
last year is obviously not a lot i do it
because i feel a moral responsibility to
limit my harm and because i'm a somewhat
public figure and so my actions may
influence the actions of others but this
emphasis on individual actions being how
we'll stop climate change is a lie
and possibly the biggest failure ever in
environmental messaging in the early
2000s spurred on by increasingly
confident climate scientists
environmental organizations launched
campaigns for people to take personal
responsibility for climate change
suggesting actions that would reduce
their individual carbon footprints even
an inconvenient truth after outlining an
existential threat to humanity peter's
out on a note of more efficient light
bulbs and inflate your tyres the idea
was that green is as green does if
someone can be convinced to take
environmental actions over time they may
come to identify as having an
environmental world view so installing
more efficient light bulbs is the foot
in the door from which someone can be
convinced to take more meaningful
actions but it wasn't just environmental
groups oil giant bp via the advertising
group gilvy and mather coined the term
carbon footprint and in 2004 released a
carbon footprint calculator for users to
assess their individual impacts on the
climate for some reason big oil wanted
you the consumer to be very aware of
something called your carbon footprint
hmm that's not suspicious at all as a
result of these campaigns governments
caught on and launched their own
environmental campaigns such as the
power of one in ireland and the one ton
challenge in canada based on the idea
that every individual can make a
difference did it work
getting individuals to take small
actions did not result in eventual large
actions that actually brought down
carbon emissions it was only with the
implementation of large-scale
legislation like the kyoto protocol that
we actually saw emissions in these
countries start to come down in fact
there are plenty of people who would
argue that these campaigns were never
about trying to fix the problem but were
instead all about shifting
responsibility george marshall writing
in the excellent don't even think about
it one of my recommended climate reads
says that the campaign sought to make
climate change the responsibility of
consumers not of governments and this
tied in with a broader political
ideology they were being extremely
political and framing climate change
within a wider neo-liberal ideology that
promotes private property rights and
free markets as the left-wing
sociologist ulrich beck said we are all
now moral entrepreneurs laden with
personal responsibility but with no
access to the actual decisions
is it time for the tin foil yet no no i
think that was pretty fair i'd argue
that these campaigns achieved three key
outcomes firstly they successfully put
emphasis on the tailpipe not the
wellhead what i mean by that is that
climate change became a problem for
people using oil in their cars not for
the people extracting oil from the
ground or indeed i don't know the
government because if it's not the
government's problem the government
doesn't have to make any tough decisions
about it you have the power instead the
power of one secondly they divided
people those that recognize that climate
change was a real threat further
identified as environmentalists while
those that didn't saw this as confirming
their suspicion that the real threat was
environmental liberals who wanted to
control their lives that division
needless to say made large-scale action
beyond the individual more difficult and
lastly they prevented systematic
meaningful change i'm sure i don't need
to tell you that reusing plastic bags
and keeping your tyres inflated isn't
going to stop the planet by warming 2
degrees celsius we require nothing less
than a fundamental restructure of how
our society generates and uses energy
devolving the responsibility to
individuals makes that level of change
basically impossible and it's only been
with a shift away from the individual
towards the national and sub-national
with governments adopting more
aggressive policies that we've actually
started to see that transition slowly
happen so let's go back to this article
what does it do
it perpetuates the idea of the
individual response to climate change it
makes people feel better about their own
inaction on climate hey at least they
don't have a private jet delaying
meaningful action it's the system
protecting itself mainstream media
putting out articles to distract us from
actually taking down the fossil fuel
investing media owning tycoons
of course i'm well aware that at the top
of the article it clearly states we need
to dismantle the fossil fuel industry
and this video is using that article as
a jumping off point but the fact is
getting angry at taylor swift isn't
gonna accomplish anything taylor for the
record you are having an oversized
impact on the climate though you don't
need to fly this much have you ever
heard of zoom what will make a
difference however is working on a
larger scale we do have limited access
to the relevant decisions when we work
together voting out governments that
don't take systematic change seriously
and democratically pushing through top
level reform which could be for example
a carbon tax as well as more targeted
reforms such as a frequent fire levy
sorry taylor taking subsidies away from
the fossil fuel industry and instead
investing in subsidies in home
insulation and interconnecting renewable
energy grids we need to kill this idea
that the responsibility to fix climate
change lies with individuals yes i think
there is a moral argument to reduce your
individual impact anyway as i do but
while the idea of tailpipe over wellhead
persists we hamstring our ability to
transform our energy system while we may
not have much power as individuals
collectively we have the greatest power
of all in the form of democracy and
expediting and enabling the relevant
policy decisions through activism
are only going to get out of this
together
i mentioned earlier that in stark
contrast to taylor swift i don't fly but
i recognize that for many people that's
not an option and the aviation industry
will carry on in the future it will
however probably look very different in
the future in order to limit its carbon
footprint and some of the technologies
that it's going to use to do that are
outlined in engineering the future a
series of documentaries covering wind
solar tidal and fusion power as well as
shipping and aviation all available on
curiosity stream curiosity stream is the
number one source of high quality
documentaries on the internet with
hundreds of titles across science
history politics and street magic
you can get access to curiosity stream
at curiositystream.com
simon clark for 26 off but wait a minute
what's this half of the screen why
that's nebula by signing up to curiosity
stream you also get access to nebula the
streamy award nominated streaming
service run by some of youtube's best
and brightest creators jam packed with
exclusive content and enjoyed by over
half a million users if you like this
video then you'll enjoy my bonus videos
on nebula watching nebula is like
watching youtube but with no ads
additional content and a hand-picked
selection of educational creators that
you'll love so head to
curiositystream.com simon clark to get
access to the best of big budget
documentaries small budget indie
productions and most importantly 26 off
with thanks to curiositystream and
nebula for sponsoring this video thank
you so much for watching this incredibly
necessary and serious video i do
seriously hope that you took something
away from it especially around this idea
of individualism versus systematic
change if you did enjoy it please do pop
it a like and leave a comment below
bonus points if you can include taylor
swift lyrics in your comments here's
some recommended viewing next and that
just leaves me to say thank you again
for watching and i'll see you in the
next one